sadly I feel like this year has just
been there have been a lot a lot of dark
moments yeah it's Lisa Marie Presley
will be laid to rest at Graceland you
posted a great picture of the two of you
together I'm in my mind we were related
but some people say that you look alike
here's the deal I was so shocked and it
kicked my butt because she's 54 years
old and I'm 58 and you just when you go
through something like this it's just
bizarre
it's hard it's hard to comprehend yeah
do you have any words of comfort to her
daughters no I'm not going to say
anything because I just don't think
I just don't think it would be
appropriate because a mother has lost
her child and I can't imagine
I can't imagine I'm not one of those
people that says you know I'm praying
for you yeah or my you know my prayers
and my condolences because I've been
going through it myself
and it's so heavy it's too heavy to talk
about it right now maybe in some time
when we give it some time for things to
settle
I just think right now I can't imagine
what they're going through so
I know what I went through and when
people say
stuff like you know they're in a better
place I don't want her to be in a better
place I want her to be here with me
that's selfish but that's human response
so the human response for me is just
love the ones you're with love the ones
you're with that and forgiveness
forgiveness forgiveness that's on my
list every single day
[Music]